professor of year last year was Adam
Carrington who's always made me feel old
because you know he studies things like
what I've studied and teaches things
like what I teach and I remember the day
he was in my office and I thought I I
caught myself thinking what a nice young
man and I called myself grandpa he is a
nice young man he's a gentle of merit
manner he's also a brilliant young man
he moves the students I began to hear
stories about him and you know around
here you guys all know but I'll tell you
if you're not a good teacher everybody
knows and they mostly just resign
because it's demoralizing for them you
know and we can always tell everybody
can't everybody can tell right and so
when a young one comes in here and gets
some distinction early on that's such a
reward you know for Gabler for Adam for
people like them because you see they're
making a career now and it's gonna work
and you and others like you are gonna
remember them for the rest of your lives
what a blessing they are right and Adam
is such a one
he's the adviser to much stuff pi sigma
alpha and young America's for freedom
and other annoying things
who's here from the Federalist Society
we straighten right up now haven't we
they're not gonna be activists while
they're in Hillsdale College they're
gonna remember the Lincoln quote that's
good Abigail's in class she's very good
student so Adam you know is involved in
that thing and they all come in my
office and they want to start a journal
and they want to start a lecture series
and they want to join together with
other conservative groups and Hillsdale
students produce a rival to CPAC called
Hill pack and we said no okay don't do
any of that because why because you're
here to study with Adam he holds degrees
from Ashland and Baylor he wrote his
doctoral thesis on the Lincoln appoint
Judge Steven field he's working upon a
book on why judging meant to the people
who knew what it meant back when we knew
what it meant and he is going to be a
productive author researcher and scholar
as well as a splinted teacher Carrington
[Applause]
thank you oh I don't I won't deserve
that but I'll try
president Arne Provost Whelan Dean's
staff fellow faculty and students I'm
honored to address you here during the
penultimate convocation held here at
College Baptist I certainly anticipate
as we were hearing about the grandeur of
the new chapel still I have to say I
will also miss this setting it possesses
if you look around a beauty subtle yet
profound made deeper by a history
closely tied as it is to our own and
before I begin I want to also thank some
not present the graduating class of 2018
I thank them for the honor they bestowed
upon me itself the reason I'm speaking
to you now but much more I thank them
for their years here at Hillsdale
students often talk about how much we
their teachers give them we as teachers
don't always acknowledge how much our
students give us and I want to thank
them in abstention for their many
generosities to me now a convocation
presents us with an opportunity I've
often heard it said here that Collegium
means association or partnership
Hillsdale College is a partnership we
congregate now we conv Kate now as a way
to remember that partnership and to
better understand it now what comprises
the substance of our association well
article four of our colleges
Constitution states and I'll quote the
object of this institution is and shall
be to furnish a literary scientific or
theological education and to combine
with this such moral social and artistic
instruction and culture as will best
develop the minds and improve the hearts
of the students our common task in short
is education the cultivation of the
person and the citizen and intellectual
and more
knowledge forms the substance of what we
do together but that begs a question
what can I say to you about this our
collective endeavor for I only teach
part of that greater whole
politics moreover I teach parts of that
part such as constitutional law you
could say Tertullian said what hath
Athens to do with Jerusalem
you might ask what hath Khan law to do
with biology mathematics or foreign
languages however I think that parts can
provide lenses through which to see the
whole in my case that lens is law we
think of law as a core component of
politics legislatures make them
executives and force them judiciary's
interpreted and apply them yet I think
the concept of law can speak to more
than just my field I think it can give
some perspective about our common task
to show what I mean I turn to
Montesquieu the 17th century French
political thinker though writing and
residing on the European continent he
was also the celebrated Montesquieu who
so deeply influenced our Constitution's
framers in his seminal work the spirit
of the laws Montesquieu defined law in
the following way he declared that quote
laws taken in their broadest meaning are
the necessary relations deriving from
the nature of things here he described
laws essence and its foundation first
laws essence should be thought of as
relationship the manner in which
entities interact is neither accidental
nor random on the contrary there are
necessary set connections between them
second he noted the foundation of these
relationships the origin that makes them
necessary the relationships between
entities are necessary and that they
stem from the nature of things all
beings then have a nature all that
exists contains within it an ordered
principle a purpose and that ordering
forms laws foundation the underlying
component delineating
the required relationships between
substances I think that in that broad
meaning of law resides a helpful way to
describe our common tasks at Hillsdale
College I would dare say we all study
law and I would say we do so in two
distinct ways first this concept of law
encapsulate sauer particular fields of
study building off his definition
Montesquieu goes on to say that quote in
this sense all beings have their laws
for instance he goes on to say that the
divinity has its laws God relates to the
world he argues as creator and preserver
yet God does so not arbitrarily but in
conformity with his own character and
will thus to study this relation the
divine nature underlying it means to
examine one kind of law next much huse
states that the material world has its
laws consider the movement of planets
the composition of cells the logic of
mathematics these relationships are
founded in the particular nature's of
their of their particular elements they
are an act according themselves to kinds
of laws and of course Montesquieu adds
that man has his laws the disciplines of
psychology history English foreign
languages and yes I'd say particularly
politics study aspects of these rules
from them we may know something of what
sets man's a man apart his capacity for
speech his possession of a soul his
social and his political nature in some
we live in an ordered world whose order
is discernible
in examining that order we study laws of
various kinds originating in our Creator
and defining what it is and what it
should be
this last mentioned study of man then
leads me to the second law or the second
way that law helps to define our
partnerships here at Hillsdale for an
important sense whatever else we do we
all study I would say this last form of
law the law of human beings in a broad
sense how could we not for how could we
teach without knowledge not just of what
we instruct but of who we instruct
Montesquieu helps here as well in the
same early sections of the spirit of the
laws he gives a summary of education its
possibility its objective and its
continual necessity first Montesquieu
notes education possibility can we even
attempt to what we do here should we
even attempt what we do here Montesquieu
thinks so he says so in calling man what
I titled my talk that flexible being
this flexibility manifests itself in the
capacity to adapt quote in society to
the thoughts and impressions of others
human beings can change in particular
their thoughts and impressions can alter
and learning is a change an alteration
human beings in their capacity to learn
are capable of acquiring new thoughts
new impressions new understandings
not to mention reforming those already
possessed furthermore this adaptation
takes place in society the adaptation
that is learning occurs with others a
kind of imitation of those around us
Thomas Jefferson once described man as
an inherently imitative being further
noting that this imitation was the seed
of Education in him whether for good or
ill we learn in community we learn in
relationship we learn in partnership
next beyond its possibility Montesquieu
asserts education zve Montesquieu
contrasts the knowledge of the nature of
things to the holding of what he calls
prejudices education goal resides in
replacing the latter with the former he
touches on this goal in the spirit of
the laws in this way quote I would
consider myself the happiest of mortals
if I could make it so that men were able
to cure themselves their prejudices he
also is a little sarcastic about how
well that's going to work
but he says here I call prejudices not
what makes one unaware of certain things
but what makes one unaware of oneself
the curing of prejudice to think in
Aristotelian terms is to move from
opinion to knowledge education is this
curing this movement beginning with
oneself it extends to all law to
knowledge in all of its forms
finally Montesquieu describes the
continued necessity of Education man
possesses two capacities equal in and of
themselves he can know his nature but
only on one condition
when it is shown to him Montesquieu says
thus education is a process of showing
of revealing what otherwise is concealed
education displays to us the distance in
our minds and hearts from what we should
be with guidance on bridging that divide
to the extent of our feeble powers at
the same time education assess 'ti is
ongoing for this showing of our nature
to ourselves is fragile Montesquieu
continues that man is equally capable
quote of losing even the feeling of it
your nature of your knowledge of
yourself and your nature when it is
concealed from him so I would say to
those who teach theology know that again
quoting him such a man such a being
could at any moment forget his Creator
God has called him back to him by the
laws of religion to the philosopher
recall that quote such a being could at
any moment forget himself philosophers
have reminded him of himself by the laws
of morality to my own field politics we
menaces never forget remarked guarding
man that made for living in society he
could forget his fellows and that
legislators have returned him to his
duties by political and civil laws
Montesquieu says education is as tenuous
as as it is precious it is a thing in
need of constant care constant
cultivation constant defense
thus we can't thus as we conv Kate let
us renew I say our study of the law
let us continue to examine them as found
in our chosen fields by especially what
calling us to continue our common study
the law of human beings let us embrace
education possibility let us further its
objective let us be vigilant in light of
its fragile continual necessity through
so doing we affirm our Collegium and in
that ongoing affirmation our partnership
becomes more than the sum of its tasks
for our partnership at its best is a
form of friendship that without which
Aristotle says no one would choose to
live even if he possessed all of their
goods
I am honoured and humbled to belong to
this Collegium with you teachers staff
and especially you all the students
which I still am and ever will be as
well
I am honored and humbled by your
friendship in and through it it is
itself a law of the best kind a law of
love may it ever bind us together here
at Hillsdale College thank you all very
much
[Applause]